déjà tôt ce matin une foule de
spectateurs ont fait la file au circuit
gilles villeneuve
les amateurs ont même pu apercevoir
rapidement le pilote sebastian vettel
une surprise pour ceux venus assister en
grand nombre aux portes ouvertes sur le
site la plupart vêtus aux couleurs de
leur écurie préféré quand je suis sortie
du métro est forte au monde ont une
grosse fille de même bas c'est l'fun de
voir que la famille a encore son son
éclat en ville c'est donc le retour du
grand prix du canada dans sa mouture
habituel après deux années de pandémie
au grand plaisir des nombreux visiteurs
au centre ville de montréal
ceux ci viennent de calgary
[Musique]
ce couple de nice en france les gens
sont souriants les gens vous à bord dans
la rue dès qu'ils nous entendent parler
avec notre accent français c'est nous
qui avons l'accent ici et ce dernier du
royaume uni
parmi ceux qui se réjouissent aussi il
ya les restaurateurs ses propriétaires
ici heureux de revoir les touristes
qu'il a sabré le champagne
et à quoi célébrer vraiment parce que
comme je dis j'ai la chair de poule
parce que on a tout de même passé gauche
et alexandre comme partout mais mes
collègues mes confrères qui ont des
restaurants ça a été long la moitié des
profits de l'année se font pendant le
grand prix une manne pour les
entreprises et l'industrie touristique
mais l'ombre au tableau c'est la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre qui forcera bien des
employés à prendre des bouchées doubles
il si mélissa françois radio canada mon
rêve